want to begin with a fox news alert
tonight there has been a hitch in the
highly anticipated count in the virginia
governor's race fairfax county which is
the biggest and most democratic county
in the state of virginia
will not be supplying its vote results
on time we're supposed to have early
vote shortly after seven o'clock eastern
but an hour ago a fairfax county
official announced that there is a delay
they say they need to rescan the ballots
they're going to release a partial count
quote of their early vote in person
sometime this evening bill hammer will
be tracking that for us we're also going
to talk to brit hume
trying to figure out how many votes they
need apparently just kidding good
evening and welcome to chuck carlson
tonight exactly one year from today is
the congressional midterm elections
tonight two governors races and solidly
democratic states on the eastern
seaboard may give us a preview of what
could be a tsunami to come
in new jersey where polls have just
closed finance goon phil murphy who
appears to have declared himself king of
the long-suffering goomba republic faces
a surprisingly sharp challenge from a
republican called jack citarelli
it seems impossible that murphy could
actually lose in a state where entire
cemeteries vote there are more than a
million democrats registered in new
jersey than our republicans but despite
those numbers he may come close and that
would be a deeply ominous sign for the
party of joe biden we'll know the
outcome of that race in just a few
moments of course we'll bring it to you
immediately
and then the commonwealth of virginia
previously mentioned that is the most
consequential election of the year terry
mcauliffe was once the governor of the
state he ran and won eight years ago as
a moderate a pro-business democrat a
deal maker who didn't have time for
ideology and he won big
and now he's back after four years
mcauliffe wants to run virginia again
but this time
he is a new man
like so many in his social class terry
mcauliffe has gone woke he's an apostle
for bidenism for equity diversity in the
race-based politics of everything
a few weeks ago mcauliffe announced that
parents no longer have the authority
over their own children public schools
in virginia are going to force feed your
kids racist propaganda and there is
nothing you can do about it if you
complain you're a white supremacist
mcauliffe said that repeatedly on
television and he meant it and then to
underscore the point tara mcauliffe
appeared at his final rally last night
with his only actual constituent that
would be the head of the country's most
radical teachers union randy weingarten
the person who bankrolls the democratic
party
like terry mcauliffe andy weingarten
isn't from virginia like terry mcauliffe
she's never had children in public
schools and so in that way it was a
perfect match here's part of what she
said
we know what happened when terry
mcauliffe was governor in this state
we know how things turned around in
terms of the economy
we know how things turned around in
terms of people being seen and respected
we know all of a sudden that people were
heard
parents were heard teachers were heard
she's a lot of fun would you put her at
the podium if she wasn't paying you no
of course not nobody would but did you
listen to what she said
she said that until terry mcauliffe was
the governor eight years ago certain
people in virginia were not quote seen
and respected in other words the state
was a racist hell hole and then
thank heaven terry mcauliffe bill
clinton's sketchy nearly indicted
hatchet man from upstate new york
arrived and liberated the police terry
mcauliffe is virginia's abe lincoln
that's what they're telling you
it's hilarious
here's virginia's most famous political
expert a guy who works at a local
college explaining that only bigots
oppose abe lincoln
the operative word is not critical
and it's not theory
it's grace what a shock huh
race
that is what matters and that's why it
sticks
there's a lot of we can call it white
backlash white resistance uh whatever
you want to call it it has to do with
race
white backlash white resistance white
white white white white meaning evil
cruel and bigoted
that's the case all of them including
their little experts are making for
terry mcauliffe they're telling you the
other guys are racist now they're saying
that because during election season that
usually works for democrats but what's
interesting is that in this case it is
not working glenn younkin is the
republican candidate in this race he is
not a racist he's a christian he's a
decent uncommonly gentle man too gentle
for politics in fact many assumed
and yet over the past few weeks glenn
younkin has made a powerful and moving
case for the america that most people
still want
a colorblind meritocracy where all of us
are judged for who we are as people as
individuals under god and not for how we
look
as a member of some group
that vision could get glenn younkin
elected governor we expected to find out
tonight and now these hiccups with the
count in fairfax county there's a lot to
assess tonight hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else